agnès est ce que tu t'es déjà confessé
oui à beaucoup quand tu étais petit
quand j'étais à partir de ma profession
de foi j'ai été élevé par les soeurs
j'étais au l'institut john cheese
saint-joseph j'ai appris les bonnes
manières
est-ce que tu approuve le divorce
[Musique]
oui oui je trouve ça plutôt bien de se
séparer si on s'entend pas parce que tu
as prouve que la contraception
oui est-ce que tu approuve la sexualité
hors mariage
qu'est-ce que tu éprouves
l'homosexualité je pense qu'il va est-ce
que tu as prouve l'avortement pas comme
méthode de contraception le bacon
recours
détresse oui j'ai fait des péchés
mortels alors les péchés mortels c'est
quoi déjà
je me suis appliqué à oublier toute
cette culpabilisation j'ai subi pendant
mon enfance
quel con si c est ce qu elle consistait
à m'envoyer au confessionnal à confesse
qu on la voit même où je me souviens
très bien on était dans l'est dans les
couloirs de
devant la chapelle et on se demandait ce
qu'on allait dire et c'est j'ai copié
sur les péchés de deux camarades de
classe et je me souviens que l'on
m'avait demandé de faire quelques je
vous salue marie et quelques votre père
et ensuite je me suis dit puisque j'ai
payé pour ses péchés
je vais pouvoir en lego m haies
c'est je ne savais pas du tout où ni
l'esprit à faire ces choses là comme
deux volets 20 centimes dans la dans le
porte-monnaie de ma mère et c'est le
concept du péché qui m'a donné l'idée la
recherche de visages sont donc chausser
les sept péchés capitaux
je les ai connus tu ne tueras point
donc ça c'est dix commandements alors je
sais plus je confonds tout est ce que tu
pêches par orgueil
forcément on est obligé d'être d'être
orgueilleux un petit peu par envie celle
envie qui
ce qui nous pousse à à avoir la force
d'obtenir des choses donc c'est pas mal
tout ça pas empêché source à un bonbon
moteur par lutz ou alors la luxure il ya
les
yala mme morales
qui vient s'entrechoquer avec la
l'éducation faut pas oublier j'étais
très jeune en 68
donc moi j'ai vécu la libération
sexuelle la pilule donc la luxure
je suis prête à tout si tu aimes la
personne avec qui tu es ça dépend si
cette personne ne mérite ou pas je suis
capable de me soigner de l'amour comme
sur mu et que j'avais la gangrène je
serai capable de mutiler d'un membre
je pense beaucoup de gens disent je si
j'étais handicapé je préfèrerais mourir
en jeu j'ai déjà failli mourir je
préfère être handicapé plutôt que de
mourir et
je préfère vivre sans la personne que
j'aime c'est négatif plutôt que que
négativement avec la personne que j'aime
je crois au bien et au mal mais pas dans
un sens forcément religieux type
j'ai peur de la religion puisqu'elle est
écrit par les hommes
donc elle est forcément écrites pour
mener
une masse pas très intelligente mais je
crois qu'on a besoin de croire en
quelque chose de plus grand que l'homme
puisque l'homme est très prétentieux et
je crois que ça peut s'appeler dieu et
que je crois que c'est bien de prendre
donc tu prends ça peut s'appeler comme
ça est ce que tu as déjà essayé
d'embrasser quelqu'un à travers le mur
et le confessionnal non même toit ou
tichy personne ne retint les corrections
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus